Nats ela round of applause for Team 11
hi I'm Roxie Archibald I'm from team 11
and this is Gabriel we are just a team
of two and what we worked on for the
past 48 hours was developing something
called test plus and what we found we've
had major technical difficulties so okay
well no okay well one of the major
problems I mean as you've seen this is
just fantastic all of the ideas that
have been thrown out but um in order to
really make these ideas possible and
happen in the classroom we've realized
that one of the major problems is that
it's not that standards aren't aligned
to real life 21st century skills like
innovation creativity collaboration
because the common core actually does
encompass these it's just that they're
not assessed on standardized tests so
this is currently how we are assessing
and as you can see there's no
collaboration taking place here there's
no innovative thinking at all so in
comes our plan are we using assessment
to build the next generation of citizens
know how can we assess those skills so
the idea behind test plus is that it
adds practical observation into the
standardized testing model through
technology and our plan is to leverage
current technology being developed at
the world's top universities like MIT
Harvard Stanford with their for example
here a signature track which is allows
for distant certification virtual idea
and cloud mentorship and integrate it
into the cake cold environment what does
what what can I do it makes way for
innovation in the classroom to be
widespread it expands assessment time it
assesses 21st century skills in a better
way it captures skills that aren't being
captured already it's progressive
testing and it's awesome
you just slide to the left should play
that song every time awesome thanks
seems well yeah yes what it is yeah so
essentially what it is would be an
alternative form of assessing some of
the 21st century skills using the online
technology that has already been
developed by some of the major
universities well basically we would
love you to integrate technology into
the classroom so they did play trying
out ready to do without using video or
yeah what do you do a collaborative
skills and different 21st century skills
that aren't being tested on that you can
only have maybe evaluated who would be
doing any evaluation members from the
industry just general members from the
industry would be a task to to do this
collaboratively they would be trained
for six months to to be able to certify
testers so they can successfully assess
using this technology remotely yeah ours
was mostly conceptual like based rather
than like here's a product that can
actually go through is just the idea of
there are already so many products out
there but innovation within the
classroom is not the norm across the
United States it happens in very
specific districts usually wealthy ones
because within other schools the focus
is on okay here are the standards that
are being tested when my student is
sitting here I need to focus on that
collaboration is not assessed I don't
have room to focus on those skills well
actually those are the most important
skills to really pave the way for the
future generation working in industry so
it helps so if we so if we integrate it
and it counts for the standardized test
maybe five percent or two percent for
the first three to five years then you
can a push for more teachers to be
teaching 24-0 just as much weight as the
standards that are assessed on the M
cast or the park therefore the
will be taken care of on in the everyday
setting in the classroom just as well so